oh
en 1880 dans un mexique dominé par le
pouvoir de l'argent permet ça à double
tour
quand une paysanne déterminer
rencontre une riche héritière cela crée
douce tendre une relation à passionnante
et très intéressante sur les différentes
théories économiques mais la répartition
des richesses
et quand la soif de justice les réunit à
nouveau
découvrez qu'est ce que vous faites
ligne rytas c'est la banque de mon père
c'est la mort de mon père seniors i try
quoi le duo le plus explosif jamais vu
bob didace
alors pour tout le monde du dos le
crozes salma hayek à tandem crime d'un
époustouflant maîtresse de toutes les
situations m habile pour pistonner
couteau et expert en séduction
leur secret l'art du pc
elle est vraiment bouleversée
ces pipes frapper n'importe où et
n'importe quand jetez pas d'âge et
ouasti ouakam
ça fait pas
à les payer
il a dit aux seniors i